i'm so excited that you're here well
thank you so much one of the one person
i really want to meet during a tip so um
your energy is so amazing everything
about your documentary i'm still
processing all of it because i watched
it last night and
it touched me because
you really get into in-depth about your
life as a young person and you bring up
race
thank you
you know what how
you know for you to be that raw and real
and talking about rocks being thrown at
you and dealing with all of that and a
time where you went to school where
there's segregation and went to an
all-black school yeah like have you
forgiven all that or oh i i when i
when the rocks were thrown at me i
forgave the people from the car the
white the white students at duke because
i was walking in that territory on a
sunday afternoon going to the bookstand
the news standing at vogue magazine i
forgave them because that's the way i
was brought up
you know forgive your enemies i had i
was kicked by a sheriff when i went to a
jimi hendrix concert in atlanta georgia
and i had to hitchhike home and i
hitchhiked back to north carolina and a
white sheriff kicked me that's not in a
documentary but when the white sheriff
kicked me i just kept walking because
i just felt that i was going to escape
this
southern segregationist south
through knowledge knowledge and grace
and that's what i got from my
grandmother
and my family and my church family and i
got out of that south i had to get out
of there i had to get out of there and
brown university opened the doors and
then i went to new york in 1974 and
there was freedom freedom and the war
hall was freedom
his environment do you ever visit the
south i always go home nostalgic for
home yeah yeah kind of depressing that's
in the dark too i go home to my
i go home to my family church yeah
i give a lot of money to them and family
church so i donate a lot of money to my
family church because it's a small
country church and i remember i remember
the best my family family is everything
family well no matter where you go it's
everything all this glitzy glamour the
blonde blob the bling the boom the lawn
moon
but always you can go back to family you
have the best yeah i was just
photographed by a young lady who has her
baby on set asleep
means so much because that young baby
will
remember when it was asleep on his
mother's set everybody that connects to
family you cannot be who you are if you
don't have family it's so important
someone in your family has impressed you
some teacher all my teachers and in the
documentary my favorite high school
teacher wanda garrett is in there yeah
and you go back back and talk to her
yeah we well back to our house and talk
to it and your friend was talking about
how great she looked yeah the friend was
looking her legs while i was looking at
her dior skirt like the old style skirt
she did not have a dior skirt but i was
looking at the weight her skirt was very
new look and he was looking at her legs
but this so i love mrs
and church you were talking about church
was the center of our family yeah church
style is what gave me my personal style
i grew up with my grandmother and a
house where it was just me my
grandmother and my great-grandmother and
church the attention to sunday church
going not only the clothes the hats the
gloves i'm trying to get a pair of
gloves right now before i go on set i'm
trying to go over to get some gloves
hats
everything impeccable they didn't have a
lot of clothes my grandmother had one
suit in her closet it was black from
1947 and when she took her first
airplane ride in 1988
[Music]
she was wearing that suit it was a
rothemia and it was a black suit it
lasted forever so it was you learned
about quality with very little money and
there's one thing you can always learn
is that you don't have to be rich to
have great taste
taste is something that comes from
within and from your environment
you know you may
taste can be the perfect eyeliner
chase can be the perfect eye powder or
shadows for your face
taste can be a perfect geranium in a
clay pot yeah the beauty of a geranium
in a clay pot that i learned from my
grandmother it's within what you find
yes you find beauty you find beauty in
your environment you find beauty in your
experi experiences as a human being you
find try to find beauty in everyone you
you get through the day better if you
can be positive about the word beauty
beauty and you can find beauty and you
must not
attack negative things negatively you
must always see in a stranger something
beautiful or say something nice you know
like your eyes are beautiful and your
hair is fabulous and you've got on a
fabulous look so i look for beauty i'm
starving for beauty at all times
how was your first day working at vogue
on my first day work yeah because i was
hoping to hear about that i want to know
that day you walked in
i was a nervous wreck i was insecure
wildly insecure
and i went through my first day in my
life and vogue thinking yeah
what am i doing here what did they see
in me in my first day at vogue i had
hurt my foot so i was limping but i was
nipping the very chic perilous coat of
maxi
and my first day vogue i was slightly
intimidated but anna went to took me
under her wings and i was fine i got the
confidence i had all the confidence
because my research my power my power
comes from my knowledge not from my
looks although my looks or armor so i
had on the right arm my head on the
ground metal gray perilous maxi coat but
i was limping around on a broken foot or
something and i don't know but it it was
business as usual it wasn't like a
celebration i had to get onto the task
and i had it right yeah did she give you
any advice anna wintour that you've
always kept with you
quick decisions make them fast and don't
change your mind
meetings if you're in a meeting with
adam winter and it's nine minutes long
that's way too long really if you're in
a meeting with anna winter and it's
three minutes it's a success on a
personal level right
i remember my first lunch with anna
winston we gone out to have lunch
and we sat down and the first course
came
and i was about to just
attack this fabulous pasta
and there was a fork of one piece of
penne yeah
and she said okay let's go back to the
office i mean
i i put the fork down and it was like
the launch was 15 minutes and we left
the office to go to this fabulous
restaurant lunch was 15 minutes she had
things she has things to do and so i've
learned to be very fast in my decisions
and follow my instincts yeah yeah
sometimes i make mistakes but i'm not
usually making mistakes but it's good to
make mistakes right yeah i love this
they can learn some mistakes yeah talk
about mistakes no but a fashion icon of
the decade was given to kendall jenner
and a lot of people wanted rihanna to
have it i want to know what your
thoughts are on that
she got the fashion icon of the decade
from vogue or from where i don't know
which magazine but she got a fashion
icon of the decade
well i think she represents a decade i
think the kardashians represent a kind
of cultural moment for everyone some
people hate them i love them but i think
they've done a great job for showing
this reality moment of a family through
a decade
um i think rihanna is absolutely bar
none one of the greatest greatest style
iconoclastic women in the world so is
beyonce my favorites are beyonce and
rihanna because they break the rules
they break the rules they break the
rules
so what would your advice be to
designers because your word is gossip my
advice for design is just do what you
feel and be who you are
do something take the risk and do what
you are and what you feel don't write
don't copy don't be inspired by copies
do something create your own thing and
someone will respond respect that and
respond to it and gravitate towards your
work
you are turning 70 in october yeah 69
don't push don't push the next year on
me
69
1948 honey
he's 16. okay he's 55.
69 and i'm proud of math honey don't
turn into 70 before sun
within all that experience you've had
what is the one moment that was a
pivotal moment for you in your life
chiffon i'd say i i call it i say i've
been in the chiffon trenches for decades
five decades i think the one moment in
my life was when i did get to vogue okay
and i didn't know that i did i always
wanted to be at vogue when i was 16. but
to actually make that a reality i just
don't know how i got there i got to
vogue in 1983 and i stayed and i went to
the top in vogue and that made me and
this is a dream come true and i i as i
as judge judy says
they don't keep me here for my looks
they keep me here for my knowledge
and that is my motto and i stay there
because knowledge is power knowledge
knowledge is power and knowledge is
armor so when in doubt you refer you
refer to the knowledge you associate all
the things you've
taken into i'm a succulent i devour
knowledge literature art painting poetry
everything fashion the history of
fashion and you can make it you can make
it you can make it you love the golden
girls love you watch reruns that was the
only one everything
so good it was so good it was one of the
best comic shows i love how does the
song go it goes
thank you so much for coming oh you're
so sweet thank you so much
you